this whole kind of vegan myth that we  can eat like an ape does we can eat like  a cow does  no we cannot thrive on that kind of diet  so have an animal that can take a plant  like grass which is directly getting  energy from the sun  and then captures that energy harnesses  it and because of its miraculous  stomachs can form all the foods it needs  and then we as apex predators can then  come in and eat that animal they can't  eat any of the other  grains and plants that we might want to  enjoy they're not supposed to eat those  they're supposed to eat the plants that  we cannot eat  and thank heavens for that i think  there's something beautiful about it